- In your hands, my fellow
citizens, more than mine,
will rest the final success
or failure of our cause.
And so my fellow Americans, ask not
what your country can do for you,
ask what you can do for your country.
(applause)
- I want to be a speech therapist
so that I can help those who
have difficulty communicating,
need a little bit more confidence
in the way that they communicate.
- Stay informed and really,
if you see something that's wrong,
you've gotta say something.
You've got to call your representatives
and make your voice heard.
- I will make sure that every young person
across the country is
empowered and motivated,
and has the tools and
opportunities they need
no matter what their economic
status or racial status is.
- I plan on standing up for
civil rights and women's rights
because as a black woman,
that is my responsibility that I have.
- New citizen of this
country, and this year
I am graduating from
Mass College of Pharmacy,
I will be a pharmacist
so I will make sure that all my patients
who come to my pharmacy
will be treated well,
with respect and with the
correct pharmaceutical therapy.
- We are getting more active
in our local political process
in our community.
- I think the single most important thing
that the average citizen can do
is show up to the polls and vote.
And if you can work for a
local campaign office, do so.
- Expose the issues that
exist in the communities
around us now, and will
partner with my peers
in order to make a better world today.
- Is vote.
One of the things that I looked forward to
in becoming a citizen
is the right to vote.
- Let us go forth to
lead the land we love,
asking his blessing and his help,
but knowing that here on earth, god's work
must truly be our own.
(uplifting orchestral music)